how the economic machine works in 30
minutes the
economy acts like a simple mechanism
however many do not understand or
disagree with this and this has led to unnecessary
economic hardships
i feel compelled to share
my simple very practical
economic template
although it is unusual for me it helped to
anticipate and  save yourself from the global
financial crisis
this template has served me well for over
thirty years start the economy only
seems complicated in fact it is a simple
mechanism it consists of a number of simple
parts and a huge number of repetitive
transactions
transactions are endless primarily because
it is human nature
they create three main forces that
stimulate the economy
first productivity growth 2
short-term credit cycle
and third long-term credit cycle
we will look at all these three forces and
superimpose them on top of each other so as to get a
template for understanding the course of the economy and
what is happening today
we will start with the simplest part of eq  economics of a
transaction the
economy is just the sum of all the
transactions that make it up and the transaction is
elementary you always conclude
transactions by purchasing any product you
always conclude a transaction the
essence of the transaction is that the buyer gives
money or a loan to the seller in exchange for
goods, services or financial assets, the
loan is spent in such a way  the same as money,
therefore, the sum of money spent and the
loan spent
gives the total value of all expenses,
this value and stimulates the economy
if you divide the amount spent by the
amount of this, you get the price and
all this investment transaction is the
cornerstone of the economy all cycles and all the forces of the
economic machine are set in
motion  with the help of transactions, therefore,
understanding the essence of transactions, we understand the
economy in general, the
market consists of all sellers and all
buyers entering into transactions with one
product or service, for example, the
wheat market, the market for cars, securities and
many other goods, the economy consists
of all transactions concluded in all
markets, if you add up  total expenses with
the total amount sold in all
markets you will get everything you need to know
to understand the economy everything is very simple
people enterprises banks and governments
all make transactions exactly according to the
principle I have described exchanging
money and credit for goods services and
financial assets the largest seller and
buyer
is  government it consists of two
important parts of the central government
collecting taxes and spending money and the
central bank which differs from
all other sellers and buyers
in that it controls the amount of money and
credit in the economy it does this
by influencing interest rates and
printing new money for these reasons  as
we will see the central bank is
an important player for credit
pay attention to credit credit is the
most important and perhaps the least understood
part of the economy however it is the most important
because it is the largest and
most volatile part
along with sellers and buyers to
market for transactions from  creditors
and debtors manage creditors usually want to
make more money out of the day and debtors
usually want to buy something that they
cannot afford at the moment, for example, a
house with a car or they want to invest
in their own business a
loan can help both creditor and
debtor get what they want debtors
promise to pay  the principal
amount of the loan taken plus the interest
on top when interest rates are high
money is borrowed less because
credit is expensive when interest rates are
low the number of loans increases because
it becomes cheaper to borrow
when the debtor promises to repay the debt and the
creditor believes him credit is created
any two persons can create credit on
empty  place it all seems quite
simple, but with a loan, alas, it is not so
because a loan can be
called differently as soon as a loan is created, it
immediately turns into a debt debt
is both an asset of the creditor
and a liability of the debtor
in the future when the loan and interest on
it are paid off the asset and  the obligation
disappears and the transaction is considered completed,
why is credit so important
because when the debtor receives a loan,
he can increase his
expenses  someone spent a dollar on you,
that is, when you spend more and someone
earns more when someone’s income
grows, lenders are more willing to
provide a loan because with
income, the creditworthiness of
a capable borrower has two values: the
ability to repay debt and collateral is
large  in relation to debt,
income enables him to repay the debt
if he cannot repay the debt
he has valuable assets that can be
sold to pay off the debt thanks to
this loan, paradise is more willing to
lend him money
so an increase in income leads to an increase in loans,
which allows more spending  and since
t  one is the income of the other it
leads to even more
loans and so on this very
scenario leads to
economic growth and is the cause of
cycles the essence of any transaction is that in order to
get something you have to give something in the
end how much you can get
depends on how much you produce
gradually we gain experience and this common
knowledge increases our standard of living we
call it productivity growth the
most inventive and industrious among
us increase our productivity and
our standard of living faster than the slow
and lazy
however in the short term this is not
always the case for productivity  value
in the long run while credit
in the short run is because
productivity growth changes
little and does not cause
economic fluctuations debt
because it allows us to consume
more than we produce at the time of its
acquisition makes us consume
less than we produce at the time of its acquisition
debt repayment cycles occur
in two large cycles, one lasts 5-10 years and the
other 75 hundred years although most of
us experience these fluctuations, they
are usually not considered cycles because they are
considered too close-up,
that is, daily or weekly, in this
chapter we will consider  these three forces, as if
from a distance, to see how they
interact with each other,
as already mentioned, fluctuations
do not arise due to innovation or
productivity, but primarily due to the
volume of credit
imagine for a second an economy without
credit in such an economy the only
way to spend more is to
earn more  requires more
productivity and labor the
only opportunity for growth is
to produce more because my spending
is the income of another the economy
grows whenever my or your
productivity increases
if we complete all transactions we
get a sequence similar to the
line of productivity growth
however EU credit  That is why there are cycles,
it is not the laws and norms that are to blame, but
human nature and the effect of credit,
imagine that loans are just an
opportunity to spend more
to buy something that you can’t afford, you need
to spend more than you earn, for
this you need to borrow, as it were, from yourself in the
future in this way  in the future you
determine the period of time when you
will need to spend less than you earn in
order to pay off the loan is already very similar
to a cycle, that is, by borrowing funds you
create a cycle every time this is true both
for an individual and for the
economy in general, therefore understanding the essence of a
loan is so important because it is he
sets in motion a mechanical and
predictable algorithm of events in the future,
this distinguishes credit from money money is a
means of settling transactions
when you buy beer in a bar and pay
in cash the transaction is settled immediately,
but if you buy it on credit it is
like opening an account in a bar, that is
promises to pay later
so you and the bartender created
a  asset and liability
i.e. you just created a
loan out of nothing until you pay off the
bill asset and liability disappear the
debt is not repaid and the transaction is
actually settled what most people
call money actually a loan the total
loan amount in the usa is  about 50
trillion dollars and the
total amount of money is only three trillion
remember in a non-credit economy the
only way to spend more is
to produce more and in a
credit economy you can spend more by
borrowing as a result in terms of credit for
savings and spending more and
short-term incomes grow faster
performance but not in the long term
but don't get me
wrong credit is not necessarily
something bad that causes cycles
bad when credit finances
excessive consumption to pay for which is
not possible but good when the
credit allocates
resources efficiently and generates income for  debt
repayment, for example, if you  if you buy
a large TV on credit, this does not create
income to pay off the debt, but if you
borrow to buy a tractor and with
this tractor you harvest more crops and
earn more money, then you can
pay off the debt and improve your standard of
living
in a credit economy, you can
follow the course  make deals and
see how credit creates growth
let me give you an example let's say you
earn $100k a year
and you are not in debt your creditworthiness
is $10000 let's say on a
credit card you can
spend $110k even though you
only earn $100 because your
spending is whose  -some income, then someone
earns 110 thousand dollars,
someone who earns 110 thousand dollars
and has no debts can borrow 11,000
dollars and thus spend one hundred
twenty-one thousand dollars
with an income of 110 thousand dollars,
his spending is income 3 thus
tracking the progress of transactions we  see how
this process works continuously
but remember loans create cycles and if the
cycle picks up then it will
start to fall at that we move to a
short term credit cycle
as economic activity
picks up the first phase of the
short term credit cycle spending
continues to rise and prices start to
rise this is due to the
fact that spending is fueled  a loan that
can be created from almost nothing
when the amount of spending and income grows
faster than the production of goods,
there is an increase in prices, an
increase in prices is called inflation, it is
not profitable for the central bank to have large
inflation because it causes
problems with
rising prices, and interest rates
increase with interest rates to take
fewer people can afford to borrow and the
value of existing debts is rising to
illustrate imagine that your monthly
payments on your credit card are rising
as people borrow less and
debt payments are getting higher they
have less and less free money
so they  spend less and since one's spending is
another's income
then incomes fall and so on
when people spend less prices fall it's
called deflation
economic activity decreases and
a recession occurs if the recession
becomes too severe and inflation is
no longer a problem the central
bank lowers interest rates to
cycle again  picks up with
low interest rates
debt repayments go down and borrowing and spending go up
and boom again as you can see the
economy acts like a machine
in a short-term credit cycle spending is
limited only by the willingness of lenders
and debtors to give and take credit
when it is easy to get credit there is an
economic boom
when to get  credit is hard to come into
recession and note this cycle
is predominantly
central bank controlled
short term credit cycle typically
lasts 5-8 years and renews itself
over decades note
that the bottom and peak of each cycle
ends at the mark  more growth
than in the previous cycle with
more long term why people are so arranged
they tend to borrow more and
spend more instead of
repaying debts we are so arranged
for this reason in the long run
debts grow faster than incomes and create a
long-term credit cycle
although people's debts grow  lenders
are ready to lend more and more
why
because everyone thinks that everything is going
fine
people only see what is in front of
their eyes and what is in front of their eyes
income
growth growth in the value of assets two in the
securities market we are at the peak profitable to buy
goods and services and financial assets  on
borrowed money when people borrow
recklessly it's called a bubble i.e.
even if debts are rising incomes are growing just
as fast to offset the increase in
debts let's call it a debt
load
while incomes are rising the debt load is
high at the same time the value of assets
skyrockets people are borrowing huge
amount of money to buy assets
in  as an investment, which causes
further growth in their prices, people seem
to be rich,
that is, even with a lot of debt, growing
incomes and asset values ​​help
borrowers remain creditworthy
for a long time,
but this cannot last forever and will not last
for decades
debt repayments at some
point in time debt repayments start
to rise faster than incomes which causes
people to cut back on their spending and as
one's spending is another's
income incomes start to fall causing people to
lose credit and borrow
less
debt repayments continue to rise
which causes spending to continue to fall and cycle
changes direction
this is the peak of long-term debt the
debt burden just became
unsustainable this happened in the usa europe and
in most other countries in 2008
for the same reason there were crises in
japan in
1989 and in the usa in
1929 the economy goes into deleveraging
when deleveraging people  spending less
income falling credit disappearing the price of
assets falling banks are at the
limit the stock market collapses
growing social tensions and everything
continues to unfold in reverse
with falling incomes and rising debt
payments borrowers find themselves without funds
in the absence of creditworthiness loans
stop and the borrower has nowhere else to
get money to repay  on debt,
borrowers are forced to sell off their
assets,
hastily sold assets flood the
market,
that's when the stock
market and real estate market crashes, and banks
find themselves in a difficult position with
falling asset prices, the price of
collateral offered by borrowers also
falls, this reduces their creditworthiness,
there is a feeling of impoverishment of credit
quickly
less spending is less income is
less wealth is less credit is
less borrowing and so on this is a vicious
circle
it is similar to a recession with the only
difference that the situation cannot be saved by
lowering interest rates in the
event of a recession  These interest
rate cuts stimulate borrowing and
this does not work in deleveraging because interest
rates are already close to zero so
stimulus ends
interest rates in the us were zero
during the deleveraging period of the 1930s and in 2008
the
difference between recession and deleveraging
is  that with deleveraging, the
debt burden of the borrower has simply become
unbearable
and cannot be eased by lowering interest
rates; creditors understand that debts
have grown so much that they are unlikely to
ever be fully repaid;
borrowers cannot repay the debt and their
collateral has lost value; the
debt situation is so pressing on them that
they don’t want to borrow more lenders
stop lending about the borrower
to borrow the
economy seems to have lost
creditworthiness
just like an individual so
what does deleveraging do the problem is
that the debt burden is too high and
it needs to be lowered this can be done in
four ways 1
reducing spending
2 abbreviation d  debt through defaults and
restructuring 3 redistribution of
wealth from the haves to the have-nots
and finally 4 the printing of new money by the
central bank of
modern history are familiar all of these
four ways
to cut spending first as we
just saw the people of the enterprise and even the
government tighten their belts and
cut spending to pay off their
debts  this is often called
austerity when borrowers
stop borrowing and start
repaying old debts it seems that the
debt load should decrease, but in
fact the opposite happens because
spending is reduced and the expenses of one is the
income of the other incomes fall they fall
faster than debts are repaid and the debt situation
workload usually gets worse
as we have seen spending cuts this is a
painful deflationary process
businesses are forced to cut spending
which means fewer jobs and rising
unemployment
hence the second step is to reduce debt
many borrowers find themselves unable to
repay their dues  lies and the debts of the
borrower are the assets of the creditor
when borrowers do not pay their debts to
banks people begin to fear that banks
will not return their money to them and they run in a panic to
close their accounts banks find themselves in a
lack of money and people enterprises and banks
default this severe contraction of the
economy is called a depression a
large part  depression is the
realization that the wealth that
people thought they had
never really existed go back to the bar
when you bought a beer and asked for
it to be credited to you you promised the
bartender that you would pay later your
promise became the bartender's asset and if you
break the promise and  don't pay him and
refuse to pay
at all then the asset is worth nothing it
just disappeared
creditors don't want their assets to
disappear and agree to a
debt
restructuring debt restructuring means that the
creditor will be paid less or
over a longer period of
time or at a lower interest
rate than  b  It was agreed at the outset
i.e. contracts are violated in
order to reduce debt creditors
prefer to get something than
nothing although debt disappears
debt restructuring causes an
acceleration in the fall in income and asset values
so the debt burden
continues to worsen as well as
spending cuts debt reduction is a
painful deflationary process
everything  this affects the central
government because lower
incomes and falling employment
means that the state receives less
taxes at the same time it
needs to increase its spending due
to rising
unemployment many unemployed people do not have
savings and they need
government assistance in addition to this the government
creates  stimulus program
and increases spending to
compensate for the falling economy
budget deficit government
deleveraging reaches a fever pitch because the
government spends more money than it
receives from taxpayers at that time
in the news and talk about the budget
deficit in
order to fight the deficit the government
needs to either raise taxes or borrow
but where to get the money if incomes are falling and
unemployment is rising for the
rich because the government needs
more money and since most of
all the benefits are concentrated in the hands of a
small number of people the
government is natural  raises
the luxury tax, which contributes to the
redistribution of wealth in the economy from the
haves to her husband, the
poor, finding themselves in a difficult situation,
begin to hate the rich and the haves, the
rich, the haves, squeezed in a weak
economy, falling asset prices and high
taxes, begin to hate the have-
nots, if the depression does not end
, social unrest occurs,
this can  occur not only within
one country, but even between countries,
especially if one of them is a debtor and the
other is a creditor, such a situation can
lead to extreme political
changes precisely because of this, in the 1930s
, power turned out to be flexible in Europe
a war broke out in the usa depression happened
there is a growing need to urgently
do something to end the depression
remember what most people thought was
money was actually loans
so when credit disappears people don’t
have money people need money and
who can print it the central bank
lowering interest rates  to 0, he is
forced to print money, in contrast to
reducing spending and reducing debt and
redistributing wealth, printing money is
an inflationary process and stimulating the
printing of new money money out of nothing
inevitably goes this money to buy
financial assets and government
bonds, as happened in the United States during the
Great Depression
then  again in 2008, when the us
central bank the federal reserve
printed more than 2 trillion dollars, a
lot of money was printed by the central
banks of other countries, buying financial
assets with this money, their prices are growing
and people are gaining
creditworthiness, however, this only helps those who
have finances  there are debt assets because the
central bank can
only buy financial assets with printed money, and the
central government can buy
goods and services and give money to people,
however, it does not have the right to print them,
therefore, in order to stimulate the economy
, the interaction of the central
bank and the government is required
buying government bonds the
central bank is essentially  lends
money to the government
allowing it to manage deficits and
increase spending on goods and services
through stimulus programs and
unemployment benefits
thus increasing household incomes
and government debt yet the
overall debt burden in the
economy is reduced
there is a lot of risk
officials need to
balance all four ways  in order to
reduce the debt burden,
deflationary methods are needed as a
counterbalance to inflationary methods in order to
maintain stability with the right
balance, a beautiful deleveraging can occur,
you see, deleveraging can be  beautiful
or ugly what is beautiful
deleveraging
although deleveraging means a difficult
situation getting out of it in the best possible
way it is beautifully much more beautiful
than debt fueled
imbalanced costs in the leverage stage
with beautiful deleveraging debts fall
relative to income real
economic growth is positive and
inflation is not the
problem  can be achieved with the
right balance the right balance
is a combination of
spending cuts debt reduction
redistribution of wealth and money printing
to maintain economic and
social stability often asked
will printing money increase
inflation no if money printing is
to compensate for falling
credit levels remember the main thing is spending
a dollar spent paid in
money has the same effect as a
dollar spent paid in
loans prints money and the central
bank can compensate for the disappearance of
credit with  In order to increase the amount of
money available, in order to change the
direction of the economy, the
central bank needs not only to
fuel income growth, but also to ensure
that income levels grow in excess of
interest rates on accumulated debt.
deleveraging process with a debt
load of one hundred percent
this means that the amount of her debt is equal to the
amount of the country's total income per year
now let's say that the interest rate on
this debt is say two percent
if the debt grows by 2 percent according to the
interest rate and income grows only
by one percent reduce the debt
the load can never be
printed so much money that the
income growth rate exceeds the interest rate
on the debt nevertheless, printing money is
easy to abuse because it is so
simple and people prefer to become the
rest malt r native the main thing is not to
print too much money  and not
provoke unacceptably high
inflation, as happened in Germany during
the deleveraging of the 20s, if
officials are able to provide the
necessary balance deleveraging is not so terrible,
growth does not happen quickly, but the debt
load decreases it is a beautiful
deleveraging
when incomes start to grow, borrowers
become more creditworthy  as
creditworthiness increases, the
willingness of lenders to lend increases, the
debt burden finally decreases and by
borrowing more money people can
spend more over time, the economy
begins to grow again leading to a revolutionary phase of the
long-term credit cycle although the
process of deleveraging can be terrible
if not approached correctly if
the right decisions are made
it takes about ten years
for the debt load to
decrease and economic activity to
return to normal, hence the term
lost decade, of course, the economy
in practice is more complex than in this
template, however  By superimposing a
short-term credit cycle on a
long-term one
and
then superimposing both of these cycles on a
productivity growth line, you can get a
good idea of ​​how
the economic situation was
before what it is now and how it is
likely to develop in the future.
faster
revenue because debt
will ruin you over time second don’t let
revenue grow faster than productivity
because over time you will become
uncompetitive and third do
everything you can to raise
productivity
because in the long run
this is the most important thing these are simple tips for you
and those in charge you  you will be surprised
but most people including
officials do not pay
enough attention to this template
serves me well and I hope it will be useful to you
thank you